oui c'est mignon
t'as pas dans le mille avec leur sujet
Les Bronzés ont été dépassés par leur
propre succès les 200 places du
splendide ne suffisent plus à accueillir
un public de plus en plus nombreux c'est
pourquoi ils ont transporté leur décor
au Théâtre de la gaieté Montparnasse et
pour eux c'est une grande première car
jusqu'ici il n'avait jamais joué dans un
vrai théâtre et ils sont émerveillés
d'avoir à faire la queue tu vois pour ni
réserver prendre des billets et de
revenir après
alors que là il faut se déplacer
moi je suis sûr que c'est la Formule 1
qui veut ça c'est la structure la
commande
alors expliquez-moi pourquoi vous avez
quitté le splendide pour venir à la
gaieté Montparnos parce que on refusait
du monde tous les soirs au splendides
et on se dit il y a 400 places ici on a
cherché un endroit et 400 places et puis
sur notre taille de ça
sans doute aller au Café de la Gare
quand on a joué pendant 5 ans chez soi
on connaît la scène Parker on connaît
l'endroit où on arrive comme chez nous
d'arriver à un endroit qui est pas chez
nous et avec tous les inconvénients que
ça comporte mais si ce n'est que sur la
scène on se rend pas bien
alors
des traces amitié
allô détresse amitié
je suis au bout du rouleau
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
ouais
excellent
les bronzés alias l'équipe du splendide
viennent de présenter dans leur
café-théâtre le Père Noël est une ordure
spectacle dont ils sont comme d'habitude
à la fois les interprètes et les auteurs
ce qui semble avoir fort impressionné la
critique parisienne beaucoup plus
habituée à saluer une personnalité
qu'une collectivité mais comment
écrit-on collectivement ici pas de
machine à écrire
pour le Père Noël ça s'est passé entre
les deux films on avait il fallait qu'on
écrive une pièce pour le théâtre parce
que on avait envie de jouer un petit peu
de s'amuser parce qu'on s'amuse quand
même plus au théâtre finalement alors on
avait on était parti sur un thème
c'était des rats on aurait joué tous ces
personnages de rat avec une un pauvre
béret et une queue et on avait trouvé
pas mal de choses assez rigolotes sur
les rats
et puis c'est arrivé à un cul-de-sac on
n'arrivait pas bien à trouver une pièce
intéressante
et puis alors après on a une séance
d'une grosse fierté noire où on s'est
défoulé comme ça et puis est sorti de ça
le thème d'une nuit de Noël dans la
détresse quoi et après on est on s'est
branché sur une lune de Noël à SOS des
traces quoi des tresses amitié qui est
un organisme on peut téléphoner quand on
veut du secours
de vieux j'ai pas trouvé taxi pour
revenir excusez-moi et puis vous avez
encore fait une bêtise pierre votre beau
manteau pierre qu'on avait vous faites
et c'est Noël je les partages avec un
malheureux
vous savez j'ai pas besoin d'en entier
Thérèse c'est réversible alors a quoi à
gauche au pingouin à droite et puis
voilà
j'ai donné la moitié où j'avais mon
portefeuille je veux dire on travaille
tellement ensemble tout le temps que les
idées on peut pas dire on part en
vacances où on voit pas pendant trois
mois et puis quand on revient à chacun
une idée on est tout le temps ensemble
c'est une espèce de bouillon de culture
d'idées si je puis me permettre
minuit
on attend que c'est calme oui finalement
à minuit c'est toujours le coup de feu
joyeux Noël
c'est formidable c'est ta gilet
c'est super je suis ravi Thérèse je suis
ravi moi j'ai hésité j'avais d'abord
pensé du vert bouteille comme je sais
que vous aimez bien oh je me suis dit
dans ces coloris là ça changera mais non
vous êtes tout à fait raison regardez le
grill le bordeaux ça va avec tout
écouter
je suis ravi je suis ravi revenir
en même temps j'ai l'impression que
c'est très jaune et goûter tes rêves je
suis ravie anémone vous faisiez pas
partie de la troupe du splendide avant
ah non mais j'en fais toujours pas parti
je suis une extra vous êtes stagiaire
comment ça se fait
que
Balasko prépare son film alors ils
avaient besoin d'une remplaçante et
comme je faisais partie en un café
théâtre qui s'appelle la veuve Pichard
qui a fait ta concurrent et néanmoins
amis qui a disparu depuis paix à son âme
et que nous sommes une espèce de grande
famille ils m'ont demandé voilà de venir
remplacer Josiane
d'abord quand on écrit une pièce on sait
pas qui va jouer quel rôle souvent c'est
pas distribué à l'avance et puis on
n'écrit pas chacun pour soi parce que
c'est rare qu'on y arrive on écrit
généralement mieux pour les autres on a
plus des images de l'autre jouant que de
soi directement
ah bah voilà et ben ça c'est tout la
sécu ça il vous donne un numéro ça a
même pas le message regardez évidemment
c'est pour la date de naissance là
surtout alors on fait le c'est une pouf
chose c'est une pauvre victime c'est un
cas social mais qu'il sait pas qu'il y a
une pêche terrible qui vachement battant
qui vachement combattant alors qu'en
fait c'est vraiment cet endroit humain
quoi est-ce que c'est chouette à jouer
oh c'est génial c'est génial parce que
comme bon je me mets un truc qui me
transforme la figure que je vais te
montrer
tu as l'impression que tu peux faire des
choses que tu ne peux pas faire quand tu
as ta vraie petite figure à toi avec tes
cheveux et tes yeux et une normaux tu
vois tu as l'impression que tu es
protégé ce qui fait que moi ça m'a
vraiment ouvert énormément de
possibilités ça va permettre d'aller
vachement loin vachement fort dans
l'intensité dans la dans la dérision
dans la méchanceté dans dans la
vulgarité tout ça c'est vraiment finir
oui c'est mignon
ça dépend
évidemment on vous demande de répondre
par vous ou par non alors ça dépend ça
dépasse
quand même X
e
pour les femmes
maintenant de la jeune fille je lui
donne deux points épouser souvent y
alors moi j'ai mis Zoza qui est posé ah
mais c'est un boulevard cette pièce est
un boulevard je pense qu'il ne faut pas
dire parce que cette pièce se joue
maintenant un théâtre oh c'est dommage
c'est un boulevard cette pièce a
toujours été un boulevard c'est un
boulevard il se trouve simplement que
maintenant nous sommes dans un théâtre
ça se voit plus nettement et plus
clairement faire une pièce sur un
organisme de répondeur au téléphone
c'était pas très scénique on s'est dit
il faut il faut faire intervenir des
gens et on a bâti toute une espèce de
structure comme ça de vaudeville
mon père Noël
et qu'est-ce que c'est que ce personnage
tu n'es pas c'est un parasite voilà le
terme c'est un parasite est-ce que c'est
agréable de jouer ce genre de personnage
ténébreux il y a rien de plus ennuyeux
je vois j'ai de la chance j'ai un fusil
qui m'a un peu marqué dans dans ce genre
de personnage et je m'en réjouis parce
qu'il plus dans le milieu que de jouer
les des belles gueules ou des jeunes
depuis 3 ans j'adore ça et je n'ai plus
de vie de femme d'ailleurs je ne porte
pas plus mal
toi ça a été un petit peu un tremplin ça
même été un grand tremplin le planning
vous voyez enfin un tremplin c'est pas
fini quoi alors
alors
vous êtes contents
[Musique]
de réservations par téléphone déjà ça se
passe bien
quand les gens rentrent là comme il y a
personne qui leur dit pour les histoires
de balcon numéroté et tout ça fait
souvent un petit
peu
voir le monde que tu as c'est tout c'est
vrai qu'ici
quand même 15 fois plus le pied que chez
nous plus la salle est grande plus il
faut être précis et et c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui est bizarre et est-ce que
le public elle-même
différence de réaction entre les gens
qui viennent nous voir au splendides et
les gens qui viennent à l'agriculture
est-ce que ça compte pas pour vous
jouer parce que c'est des lieux qui ont
été fabriqués pour jouer la comédie nous
on a quand même joué dans des garages
dans des hangars aménagés et eux ils ont
quand même il y a des architectes qui se
cassaient le cul pour essayer de se
montrer agréable d'avoir autre chose que
50 cm d'air on pose toute sa tête comme
l'hôtel et chez soi si tu veux quand tu
as un studio ou maison tu vois et tu
arrives à l'hôtel c'est nickel mais
c'est pas cher
pardon si il fait semblant de croquer
c'est un conseil
vous n'en prenez pas monsieur mortel non
euh
[Musique]
c'est pas forcément c'est peut-être ça
mais c'est pas forcément expliqué comme
ça non on n'écrit pas en disant on va
faire une ceinture sociale on écrit
vraiment ce qu'on sent il se trouve
qu'on regarde peut-être les gens avec un
un peu particulier
une fois pour toute une adulte voilà je
t'explique quelquefois à l'improviste
l'amour fait l'intrusion dans la vie
d'un homme et il est obligé de le suivre
qui quand ils sont arrivés qu'ils ont
construit leur truc et tout ils ont
commencé pratiquement en même temps que
nous un peu après mais ils étaient déjà
fait
le premier spectacle en détail voir chez
eux étaient écroulées en crevettes
jalousie c'était pas du tout il y avait
pas des anciens et des nouveaux non mais
pour eux ce qu'ils ont fait ils
l'avaient appris en voyant vos
spectacles
non ils avaient simplement appris qu'on
avait le droit de faire comme ça et on a
été enthousiasmer
et puis 4 ans après il se trouve que
quand on avait monté un spectacle ils
étaient des nouveaux qui nous ont dit
c'est bien ça nous plaît c'est un peu
dans le même genre c'est eux qui nous
ont quelque part donner l'idée de
construire un théâtre
un patron
je vais pas faire de chiji je t'aime pas
c'est chouchou que j'aime tu es content
de toi
oh c'est une blague je te le dis tu es
bouché
[Musique]
théâtre on avait l'impression de voir
une pièce qui était très satirique très
corrosive c'est d'un seul coup ici
le contraire il y a des gens qui nous
ont dit que au théâtre et trouver la
pièce beaucoup plus grand centre que ce
qui est beaucoup plus méchant que ce
qu'il avait vu au café théâtre
de réaction et ça ne les étonnait pas
quand ils voyaient dans notre salle
alors qu'ici il y a un recul comme il y
a vraiment la structure
ou des choses qui sont décalage comme ça
au café desa tu dis euh
je crois que vous suffisamment mal pour
ce soir
l'écraser comme une punaise le Père Noël
c'est une ordure il réussisse parce
qu'il reste ensemble il pense que ça
vaut le coup de rester ensemble même si
on a des années dans une équipe parce
que c'est une équipe qui doit gagner
[Musique]